Welcome back to Computer Vision.
This lesson is going to start
a whole unit on motion.
Now, in the real world,
things really move, you know,
wind trees blow in the wind,
boats move along the water.
A baseball player swings his bat and
typically misses if he wi,
if he plays for the Mets.
But, you know,
things are moving all the time and
our perception system handles them.
In Computer Vision, we also want to deal
with motion, but what's kind of cool is,
actually, nothing is moving.
What you're seeing here is
a repeated GIF image, and I've,
I've made it sort of
coarsely sampled actually,
it's from some slides stolen
from some folks listed below.
So that you can see that it's
actually a sequence of static frames.
Okay?
And, you know, of course,
the issue is that when we look
at them when they're not so
separated in time by quite so
much we see this nice motion.
And what we would like is, that the same
perception of motion that we have,
we'd like to be able give the machine.
We'd like a machine to be able
to understand the notion of
motion, if you will.
So, when we're going to
talk about motion.
Here, we're going to start
talking about video.
Now, really, we're just thinking
about a sequence of frames.
And, in fact, a long time ago, we used
to just called them sequences because
a camera would go and then a camera
would take another picture.
And then, some time later, would take
another picture, another picture.
And the question was, how to use those.
These days, of course, much more
ubiquitous, is a notion of video where
a sequence is captured over time,
usually, relatively quickly.
So things can't change a whole lot
from one sequence sample to the next.
And usually taken at regular intervals,
whether it's every 30 hertz, 60 hertz,
24 hertz, the idea is that
it's at regular intervals.
Now, our image is no longer
a function of just space, x and y.
But our image is a function of space x,
y, and time, t.
So our signal is I of x, y, and t.
But as I said before,
sometimes when we describe them as
three dimensional function like this.
We tend to think of the, all three
dimensions as being the same, but
they're not.
Space is quite different than time, so,
if I wearing a nice checkered shirt
instead of this gorgeous green.
As I moved in space, you would
see pixels changing very quickly
in terms of their
intensity of their color.
But, if I were to change
the pixels that quickly in time,
you would essentially see a mess,
you would see all this flickering and
things changing very rapidly.
So in general, even thought we think of
these as a three dimensional function,
remember that time and space are
different in terms of their statistics